musk starts to cleanse Twitter of lame
comedians
on Sunday African immigrant Elon Musk
threatened to permanently suspend
Twitter accounts that pretended to be
someone else without being an obvious
parody which is why the person tweeting
for Joe Biden is safe
this rule was already in Twitter's terms
of service but those are read even less
than Brian kilmeade's books
musk announced this after several
attention Seekers started impersonating
him former comedian Sarah Silverman
changed her account to look like musks
and tweeted I am a freedom of speech
absolutist and I eat Duty for breakfast
every day
thankfully it's the first time she's
impersonated an African without this
lady wore blackface and thinks free
speech absolutist is an insult her
account is still active not active
career Kathy Griffin also impersonated
musk tweeting she would only be voting
blue users could still tell it was Kathy
Griffin because it wasn't funny
although her ban was allegedly permanent
most later tweeted that she could have
her account back for eight bucks she can
get her face back too by injecting algae
that eats plastic did you know that I
did not know that but if you're bummed
that she's gone and you miss her brand
of Comedy try slamming your head with a
car door
other celebs have left Twitter as
protests but at least one is already
back barely a week after announcing he
was quitting Twitter actor Ron Perlman
slithered back to bash must comments on
stuff he begins just popped back on
because I couldn't let this one slide
yeah he just popped back on yeah his
quitting is like a hunger strike with
lunch breaks
it's like telling someone you're done
with them forever then calling to say
you're coming over but only to retrieve
the ballpoint pen you left at their
place
which reminds me Jamie I need that pen
back
yeah
so what do you know what's interesting I
feel like Jamie that a lot of these
celebrities they kind of see they they
have this Arrested Development so they
see everybody like the gym coach doing
detention and they're like The Breakfast
Club it's like you know versus Trump now
it's Elon Musk it's like I'm gonna get
back at this billionaire on Twitter by
going on Twitter yeah yeah it's come and
what's what is I saw headlines and I was
like wow is Elon really like not letting
people joke around he just wants people
to not pretend they're yeah him like
parody and jokes are totally fine which
is kind of different than the way it was
represented I don't think you should be
able to pretend you're so you know I
mean for real like that's I don't know I
I don't mind him doing that at all as
the CEO I do think he might be a little
bit too accessible yeah to people do you
know what I mean like the number one
rule when you're trying to be famous is
like don't read the comments and Elon is
reading the comments maybe it's done
differently on his planet or whatever
but I think he should not do that do you
know I no joke I I'm a little I mean
I'll pay eight dollars a month but I
think the verification was very useful
maybe for someone that doesn't have
eight bucks because it does help people
from impersonating you like that was
that's the one thing it does do that's
beyond like marketing or whatever I had
someone impersonating me on Twitter and
it was really bad this person was an
idiot so people totally fell for it and
thought it was me
but no joke fans of this show he would
um message them and set up like dates
and stuff and I got messages months
later from like some women that were
like Oh I thought we were meeting up not
kidding at all so I had to go through
hundreds and hundreds I had to sleep
with hundreds and hundreds of women
thank you
you are the true
hero in all this yeah God bless I uh you
know Dana um will you ever consider
leaving Twitter I know I don't want to
go yeah sometimes I do and then like Ron
Ron oh my God I just get by
um I think that I don't think I would
miss it that much but I realize I do I
use it a lot for work okay so I'm
constantly looking what is the update
what's the update I'm looking for guys
tweets so I know what to say
um but I actually have found that
there's less of that available a lot of
it is kind of nonsense now and I have
hopes for Twitter on the other side Bill
hemmer said he would pay my eight
dollars a month so I figure I might as
well stay wow wow Hammer must like you
he's never paid for anything for me guy
I'm caught up on the blackface photo of
Sarah Silverman which I did not know
happened am I mistaken or did she not
date Jimmy Kimmel yes who also did black
face did they do like blackface dates
yes exactly that's how they shared the
paint they would just put the paint and
make out and they'd both be blackface
wow sorry like I forgot what the actual
topic is I'm still I'm just ruminated is
that incredible there's a whole like Sub
sub industry of blackface Comics yeah
and they're all like they're fine yeah
his ratings aren't fine but you know
he's not canceled yet uh in either way
but yeah the one thing about Elon was
his tweet today did you see this where
he endorsed Republicans yes and just a
complete total meltdown on the left
because he said we should have checks
and balances maybe we should vote
Republican this time and people lost it
he is like getting close to Trump levels
of trolling yeah it is impressive yeah
yeah I think he has taken up the space
that Trump had yeah and because he's in
every like you know Kat if you notice
every single story could be related back
to now Twitter or to musk before that
you could relate it back to Trump yeah
that's true and a lot of the headlines
were saying that you know she was banned
Kathy Griffin was banned for you know
mockingham which it was the
impersonating thing I get that I also
think a permanent suspension would not
be fair I think that she look she's
obviously joking that's like all she
ever does I don't think anybody goes to
her for like serious news analysis at
least I hope not
um and if she's intending to make a joke
then I think that should be taken into
account no matter who it is I know a lot
of people really hate Kathy Griffin and
they're happy to see her getting banned
because a lot of people were maybe on
the right you know they got banned for
things too but I don't I'm never one for
like the Tit for Tat yeah I think that
at some point they just let everybody
back on unless yeah you know that just
you just ban him and then you bring it
back because that's what I think that's
where we're going with all this but what
do I know
oh a lot actually everything everything
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else